would you say that filmmakers today are
more about forcing a message than
telling a good story that's a great
question
i think i think there's there's quite a
few that do that
i think telling a good story is
important whether it's it's you know a
fun
[Music]
you know romp in the desert or it's a
story about a collapse of
you know the housing industry like you
know the big short i mean wow was that a
message or was that a story yeah i think
it was both
i really do will we learn from it time
will tell
i think set your watch to that but
um
you know i think you know as
storytellers we have a responsibility
as writers we have a responsibility um
a lot of people you know i think i think
well if you look at the faith based
genre it's all about the message they
don't care about story as much as they
do it's the message it's the message
it's the message and um
you know that's cool that's that's their
thing
um
[Music]
you know sometimes the story is good i'm
not saying they're not always but
there's there's it's message
is the integrity and the point behind
those
you know i don't
you know i don't know
what
what different artists intent is i think
some people go in with the intent to
tell a good story and it becomes message
heavy
and i think the other way around too
sometimes people go on wanting to give a
message and it ends up being a good
story or you know it doesn't
i think i think everybody as a
storyteller
has an intention whether they're willing
to
show their hand
or
really
you know i think the good storytellers
are able to do both
without people realizing what's
happening i mean i think when you can
seduce an audience and kind of woo them
along and really get them in your story
regardless of what story you're telling
whether it's chariots of fire i mean you
talk about that that was a faith-based
movie
people don't realize that that you know
eric little not not
competing on the lord's day and the
background of his religious background
there was a lot of religious undertones
in that but it was a hell of a story and
it was such a brilliant film
and you know
was it message driven or was it story
driven i think it probably was a good
hand of both
in my opinion anyway
you know looking on golden pond
you know henry fonda and jane fonda i
mean there was a story there but there
was such a message about family and and
communication
and and how we drift apart with age and
circumstances but
you know i think there's a way to do
both
but
your question was do i think one one
this is people become more focused on
one or the other i think
as we go through what we have in our
times i think i think a lot of people
run to a message as storytellers i think
that's a big thing
i i see a lot of short films and theses
films that are message driven
and they're not thinking about the story
as much but that's that's coming from a
lot of film school students and you know
newbies that
they they want to jump on a cause and
and sometimes just saying there's
anything wrong with that i think you
know
i think sometimes when you when you're
dealing with sensitive issues or you're
dealing with
subject matters that we're still really
feeling
you know the aftermath or the aftershock
from
um that's a that's a good way to get
some attention as a storyteller to to
let people see what it is that you're
trying to do as an artist and sometimes
you have to
you have to to pick the scab a little
bit
you mentioned that taxi was one of your
favorite shows growing up was there a
message with the tv show
poof was louis de palma was he
did he have something that he was trying
to tell us and we didn't see it i think
he was just a i think you know i always
thought danny devito was the youngest
of probably five children
and he probably you know like arthur
spooner and the king of queens never
really was heard growing up
and he was a bully and you know the
funny thing was is he was you know
five foot nothing 100 and nothing and
you know ran the roost it was his show
you know i mean it was his is that it
was his garage
and there was there was messages but you
know occasionally he would have a life
lesson but before they faded to black
he'd always slide back to old louis
right that's true but but the things
that john hirsch's character would would
go through with you know tony danzer
elaine or you know
bobby wheeler's character i forget his
name the actor that passed um
and you know my favorite was jim
mcdonkowski christopher lloyd's
character i mean that was my favorite
character
i watched the show for him as a kid i
thought he was hilarious and latke vodka
was great
yeah yeah and latke's wife yeah yeah i
mean was there a message you know i
think you talk about people coming from
all different backgrounds and all
different you know walks of life and
being able to work together and
encouraging alex was always kind of that
wise owl of the group you know they went
to him for advice or
sometimes he got himself in a pickle and
you know elaine would help him out you
know so i i think it's neat when shows
that we and dear
touch on us without hitting us over the
head and i think taxi was a brilliant
example of
of giving us little life lessons without
ever feeling like we were being preached
at
you know i like shows like that
don't hit me over the head you know let
me enjoy the people the circumstances
and go along for the ride and oh you
happened to give me a little life lesson
here all right it was it was extra worth
the time
whereas with fantasy island there was
always a message
usually there was wasn't there once you
know when
mr work
was was
speaking to tattoo at the end
there there was some kind of a message
that that show was on past my bedtime i
never got through the third act
i don't know if they'll have the same
message in the remake
but it looks like they've really
rebranded it i like the fact that they
have a woman now as the
mr roar character i think
it appears that way i haven't seen it
yet but looking at some of the previews
of it i think they have a woman now
leading the charge which i think is
great
um you know but yeah there were messages
i know there was about people finding
love or i think wasn't it
again forgive me
uh i think it was also a lot of people
fantasies chasing something that they're
never gonna get and being able to accept
and love and appreciate what they truly
had as they think what kind of was the
underlying tone of the show wasn't it
as an audience member or fan do you feel
that movies today are lecturing you more
than they previously did not the stuff
that i watch
i don't i don't allow myself to get into
that i i i'm very you know
time is precious our time on this earth
is limited
you know um
something doesn't doesn't get me early i
just i have an off button like the rest
of the world i just i just don't
go down roads that i just feel if
something's going in a direction that i
don't personally agree with or
it just doesn't hold me i i don't wait
it out you know i'd rather go on and do
something else um so i i can't answer
that
um
i just you know
i like shows that allow me to
do the things that i want to do when i
tell a story let people go where they
haven't gone take them someplace they
didn't know existed i let them just
forget about their circumstances and
enjoy something for 90 minutes or
however long it is that they're watching
um
but you know
i i always love it when there's
something
you know there's always that saying when
we work on something we always we always
try to leave the audience with something
you know more than an empty box of
popcorn at the end of a show i think is
i think i think it's a filmmaker's
responsibility i mean no matter how
ragtag or crazy a show is i think
i think there's always i think show
always needs heart you got to have
characters you care about and can relate
to so i think it's important that you
know as storytellers we allow our
audiences to relate to characters or at
least want to learn more about a
character and if we
have some self-discovery during the ride
super that's great
i don't look for films like that or
projects like that
when i watch something
[Music]
but you know i like nice surprises as i
said earlier i think sometimes when you
walk away from something wow you know i
gave me a different point of view or i
never thought of that or
really interesting to see a different
side from you know of society that maybe
i don't come in contact with all the
time and to see their upbringing their
point of view or you know one of the
shows that i'm absolutely
in love with
is um
blanking on the name right now it's
snowfall
john singleton created that show and you
know basically about the beginning of
crack cocaine in the inner cities and
how that started
um i think that is just such a brilliant
show and i
having come up working with you know
incarcerated youth during that time we
were really big in working with you know
a lot of the juvenile inmates and in the
prison system during those 80s and 90s
and
i was very involved with a lot of the
kids lives that were going through you
know slinging dope and making crack and
selling it and living in gangs and
protecting their turf
and you know here i am 25 30 years later
as you know 50 year old guy watching
this show
it's like one of my favorite shows on tv
and that's something that i saw close up
it wasn't you know living the life but i
was close to it and you know integrated
with people that were
i just think you know you talk about a
show that
you know you i think you learn so much
about the mindset of
you know it's a lot of people that it's
easy to
look down on people that live a certain
way and do a certain thing to make money
but you also have to look at the
circumstances and what their
surroundings are and either you're
selling or you're living on the streets
broke or you're selling or you're going
to die because there's a lot of people
that got pulled into it that you had to
choose an allegiance
so a lot of the people that got involved
in that they didn't really have a choice
and a lot of people you know it's good
to remind people where things come from
i mean i think there's some some
interesting roads they go down with the
cia
funding some of that to kind of do their
own thing and that's that's all you know
if you're into that that's cool i mean i
don't take one side or another on that
but i i love the show because i care
about the characters you know we we meet
franklin and he's
this young
kid who lives in the hood who gets
brought into this underworld and he
becomes a kingpin of moving narcotics
into the not only the inner city but our
our world
and you know stories like that fascinate
me and i think a lot of people get that
from shows like narcos and
other shows i haven't seen that one but
you know i sometimes there's message you
know there's
interesting interesting things that come
from those about relationships and
loyalty
and you know sometimes i can get
inspired by a show like that that has
nothing to do with what i'm dealing with
on a day-to-day basis but it reminds me
of the importance of loyalty when i
think of our film crew or i think about
the people that we work with or our
friends or family
you know so it's nice when those little
those little things happen when you
watch a show that you don't expect it
from